[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette suite
l'hebdo le retour sur l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines
voici les titres de ce vendredi 9
octobre le monde de la nuit subi de
plein fouet la crise sanitaire les
boîtes de nuit en particulier
fermée depuis le 15 mars leur avenir est
incertain
pareil pour les professions qui
gravitent dans ce secteur comme les dj
témoignages dans les yvelines pour notre
entretien hebdomadaire nous recevrons
pierre françois wiart le maire de la
commune de louveciennes ou deux
discothèques sont justement situé on
parlera également de l'impact de la
crise sanitaire sur les finances de la
ville
enfin des inquiétudes chez les
restaurateurs le gymnase du moulin à
vent de coignières ouvert ou encore le
lancement du mois octobre rose
voici ce qui a fait l'actualité cette
semaine et c'était l'actualité du jour
cela faisait presque quatre ans qu'elles
étaient retenus au mali
la dernier otage française dans le monde
sofi petrona a été libéré jeudi 8
octobre est de retour en france elle a
atterri à la base aérienne 107 de
villacoublay
ce vendredi midi où le président
emmanuel macron et ses proches
l'attendait le chef de l'état s'est
ensuite entretenu avec elle en privé cet
humanitaire de 75 ans avait été enlevée
le 24 décembre 2016 à gao au nord du
mali elle vivait sur place et dirigé là
bas une organisation dead à l'enfance
qu'elle avait fondée en 2004 avec sophie
petrona deux otages italiens et
l'opposant politique malien soumaïla
cissé ont également été libérés
comme je vous le disais en titre nous
allons maintenant parler du monde de la
nuit les boîtes de nuit ont fermé leurs
portes au début de la crise sanitaire en
mars dernier en france et ne rouvriront
que l'année prochaine au mieux dans les
yvelines ce secteur tentent de trouver
des solutions pour continuer à exister
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et de nicolas d'andry depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire l'humeur n'est pas à
la fête dans cette boîte de nuit
yvelinoise habitué à accueillir près de
1500 personnes les samedis soir
l'établissement a dû fermer ses portes
en mars dernier à cause du coc vite 19
malheureusement fermé
j'espère peut-être avant mais pour
l'instant tout dépend de ce qui va se
passer avec lui donc voilà on n'en sait
pas plus que cela
on les ferme et prendre leur temps avant
terme pour continuer à faire la fête à
distance la structure située à lucian a
créé des directs de deux heures sur les
réseaux
ils sont diffusés un samedi sur deux et
surtout garder du lien avec clients
habituels peut-être de nouveaux clients
qui viendront quand on ré ouvrir et puis
que dire des titres à chaque fois les
voir il fallait faire un tour et puis
google est vraiment ci par là et comme
enzo est vraiment le allied complètement
le live du pacha club
les performances via les plates formes
en lit certains dj indépendante
également opter pour cette option pour
continuer à mixer c'est le cas de dj
rubel l'élan courtois de 29 ans à
l'arrêt depuis le confinement à
participer à un festival en ligne le 30
août dernier aux côtés de huit autres
artistes
on a vu des choses un peu similaires à
l'étranger aux états unis en angleterre
aux pays bas et en france n'avait pas
encore vu de vraiment de vrai festival
virtuel qui donnait une alternative aux
gens qu'ils pouvaient faire la fête
régler mais chez raymond crs devant leur
télé mais qui retrouvait quelques perles
un petit peu l'énergie musicale de ce
qu'ils avaient pu connaître avant de
confinement les vidéos ont généré plus
de 200000 vue unique pour cette
performance le dj vinoy dû s'adapter à
une nouvelle méthode de travail
c'est un petit peu déroutant parce qu'il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de public
devant toi tu es tu es sur une scène de
très haut niveau technique
il ya des festivals et des clubs qui
n'ont pas ce niveau technique donc il ya
beaucoup de light vous coupent sont
beaucoup de vidéos mais en face de toi
il ya juste des techniciens un peu de
presse
le staff quand tu es habitué à jouer sur
des scènes comme ça mais qu en face de
toi tu es habitué d'avoir 1000 2000
plusieurs milliers de personnes
c'est un peu déroutant je pense qu'on le
voit un peu sur les images où je suis
pas forcément j'ai pas beaucoup
forcément de présence scénique parce que
c'est vrai que tu sais pas trop comment
de comporter quelle posture adoptée
quand tu es sur une scène comme ça qu'il
ya personne en face de toi
dj ruben devra attendre encore quelques
mois pour mixer à nouveau devant un
public il pense pouvoir faire des
événements au milieu de l'année
prochaine
nous accueillons pierre françois wiart
bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes le maire de la commune de
louveciennes avant de revenir sur le
sujet des boîtes de nuit je crois savoir
que votre commune a été fortement
touchée impacté par locaux vides au tout
début de la crise sanitaire
même avant le confinement si c'est si
c'est bien ça nous avons eu quatre cas
de quatre décès à l'ancienne dans cet
établissement
ce qui a marqué en fait le début de la
crise qu vite pour notre commune et puis
aussi je crois pour pour certaines
structures de notre département
évidemment revenons sur le reportage du
coup comme je vous le disais de nicolas
landry et mickaël ennemi d euros sur les
difficultés du monde de la nuit et en
particulier des boîtes de nuit deux
établissements de ce genre dans votre
commune l'escale club et le pacha club
qu'on a entendu justement dans le
reportage
avez vous rencontré ses dirigeants
d'établissements et puisqu'elle est un
petit peu leur sentiment en ce moment
alors j'ai été en communication très
récemment avec le propriétaire du pacha
club qui m'a fait part effectivement on
va dire de ces difficultés qui m'a dit
ce serait certainement l'une des
dernières structures à réouvrir
puisqu'il me disais que dans quand on
vient dans un établissement comme le
pacha dans une discothèque c'est pour
danser ensemble que la distanciation
social est effectivement difficile à
maintenir et que les là sont les
personnes sont là pour effectivement
danser ensemble se toucher d'où les
problèmes effectivement de contamination
potentielle pour ce qui est de l'escale
je crois qu'elle a une classification
actuellement en bar qui n'est pas une
classification en discothèque
ce qui lui permet d'ouvrir en tant que
le bar et il y avait aussi possibilités
d'accueil à l'extérieur sur une terrasse
ce qui est à mon avis mieux puisqu'on a
on sait que la contamination par le
comique 19 se fait essentiellement dans
des espaces clos
donc on ne peut que saluer le fait que
ce soit à l'extérieur
d'ailleurs nous au niveau de la commune
nous avons toujours privilégié
les espaces extérieurs pour les
manifestations tout en restant
extrêmement prudent
justement en prenant évidemment toutes
les mesures de sécurité comme de
nombreuses autres sociétés donc les
discothèques peuvent être soumises à la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises communément appelée cvae
alors ça dépend de l'intercommunalité
c'est bien ça c'est ça c'est une recette
qui va dans le dans la terre vers
l'intercommunalité tout comme la
cotisation foncière des entreprises
alors avec un certain décalage puisque
actuellement l'intercommunalité reçoit
les cotisations basé sur des 1018
prélevés en 2019 et versés à l'inter
compte 2020 mais tout ça dépendra
évidemment de la loi de finances 2021
qui sera votée par le parlement
et justement la fermeture de du pacha
club du coup en ce qui concerne votre
commune va avoir un impact financier sur
cette saison l'impact direct sur
l'intercommunalité qui reverse commune
par l'intermédiaire d'une attribution de
compensation lança une partie de ses
recettes
il faut savoir qu'on se prépare à voter
en communauté d'agglomération
une baisse conséquente de ses
attributions de compensation qui serait
de l'aube allemand je crois au tour de
l'ain 75%
si ce chiffre est et qu'on est confirmée
j'imagine pour aider ces établissements
dans la crise restons dans les finances
justement la crise sanitaire a aussi eu
un effet sur le budget de votre
municipalité
quel a été son impact justement alors si
on parle en chiffres exactement à fin
septembre
on était aux alentours de 470 milles
euros sur un budget de fonctionnement de
17 millions d'euros donc à peu près 3%
ce qui est quand même relativement
conséquents à diviser à peu près en deux
parts d'une part sur les dépenses liées
au vide je parle de masques de gel
hydroalcoolique et puis l'autre partie
sur les baisses de recettes attendu que
ce soit sur des structures que possède
la ville de restauration ou autre on a
quand même eu une
un impact notable de cette crise qu vide
les chiffres que je donne sont arrêtés à
septembre 2020 donc fin septembre 2020
d'accord et ses dépenses vous les aviez
pas budgétée évidemment est ce que pour
vous pour une commune de de louveciennes
c'est important un budget pareil dans
vous voyez 3%
mais est-ce que ça va avoir un impact
sur vos projets à venir alors on a eu on
a toujours eu alou scène une enfant tout
cas pour ma part une politique prudente
prudentielles donc que nous avons
toujours des petites réserves et on doit
dire que l'actrice qu'ovide nous a
permis de constater que le fait de
dégager des réserves nous permettait de
parer aux événements imprévus donc ça
c'était une politique prudentielle que
j'ai toujours mené pour la pour la
collectivité
maintenant ça n'est pas anodin et le co
vide la crise que vit des temps amené à
on va dire as a duré plus longtemps
puisqu'on parle voire jusqu'en 2021 va
jusqu'en 2023
ça va s'installer dans la durée donc il
faut que nos budgets aussi tiennent
compte de ces éléments là pour les
années à venir
sur le plan des prospections pluri
annuel des dépenses on l'a bien compris
mais aussi des rentrées financières en
moins c'est ce que vous m'avez
directement je pense notamment à la taxe
d'habitation qui est tombé cette semaine
pour les français est-ce que ça aussi
c'est une rentrée d'argent en moins est
ce que ça impacte votre budget notamment
la taxe d'habitation non la taxe
d'habitation les taux ont été fixé
antérieurement vous savez la taxe
d'habitation est compensé par l'état
puisque grosse partie enfin partie non
négligeable des personnes des foyers ne
paye plus cette taxe d'habitation donc
les taxes d'habitation taxes foncières
les taux ont déjà été votées pour la
taxe d'habitation les taux sont
pratiquement bloqué est compensé par
l'état pour une partie pour la taxe
foncière lettonie également été votées
dont nous sommes restés sur la même
fiscalité les mêmes taux de fiscalité
qu'en 2019 et ça a été compensé par
l'état vous avez reçu cette compensation
par rapport à la taxe d'habitation alors
ça ça oui nous avons nous recevons
la compensation il n'y a pas de problème
de ce côté là il n'y a pas eu de mesures
qui se traduisent par la peint sous
forme de textes de taxe d'habitation
taxe foncière sur ces valeurs là puisque
je vous dise pareil ces taxes
d'habitation et taxes foncières sont
reversés sont de l'année antérieure
reverser l'année d'après donc il a le
gouvernement a également annoncé une
compensation pour le budget qu vide
entre guillemets l'appeler comme ça il
m'a en fait qu'est et celle là et vous
pensez que vous l'aurez dans combien de
temps est-ce que vous allez l'avoir est
ce que vous l'avez vu je pense que nous
l'aurons et je l'espère en tout cas ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'à côté du
gouvernement nous avons eu quand même
une aide très conséquente de la région
ile de france par l'intermédiaire de
distribution de max dans une période la
période donc confinement qui était la
période plus aiguë que nous avons connus
ou la région nous a bien aidés je dois
dire en termes de masques en termes de
fourniture aussi de gand donc le
département également donc je veux dire
les différents intervenants ont été
précieux pour pour la gestion de cette
crise surtout à une période où nous
n'avions pas non plus à disposition
même en les commandant ces fameux masque
qui ont longtemps manqué et que
heureusement maintenant nous avons à
disposition sur un autre sujet mais
évidemment toujours dans la crise
sanitaire
votre métier près françois wiart ses
vétérinaires élus mais également
vétérinaire votre profession a répondu
présentes dans le cadre de la réserve
sanitaire pour cette cette crise
sanitaire
oui pensez vous que les compétences des
vétérinaires pourrait être mieux utilisé
pour la crise et pour aider les
soignants alors je pense que les
vétérinaires effet devenu fait
effectivement de leur formation
scientifique peuvent être un atout
précieux pour aider effectivement les
soignants tout et n'ayant pas
effectivement les compétences techniques
particulières excusez-moi l'espèce
humaine même si j'ai par le passé fait
une thèse de pathologies comparer entre
l'homme le chat et l'humain c'est un
petit clin d'oeil ce qu'on peut dire je
crois que nous avons quand même les
compétences pour aborder cet épisode que
vides
avec peut-être plus de réalisme et de
sérénité que certaines professions qui
ne sont pas confrontés à ces problèmes
d'épisodes virage et bhl lors d'un cadre
de mon exercice professionnel je suis et
j'ai été confronté à des épidémies et
c'est ce côté très aléatoire delà de la
pathologie de toutes ces pathologies
virales qui font que beaucoup de nos
contemporains de nos concitoyens sont
très perturbés par des des informations
qui vont dans un sens dans l'autre il
faut avoir ce recul scientifique on a la
chance de l'avoir de par notre formation
pour pouvoir analyser je dois dire que
le fait d'être vétérinaire m'a aidé dans
la gestion pour ma commune de la crise
que vides et dans mon discours vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis des habitants
alors après je pense que les huit
dernières peuvent aussi être utilisée de
par leurs compétences pour aider les
soignants et je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
de vétérinaire qui ne répondra pas
présent à cet appel
eh bien merci mes prières françois wiart
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce plateau et
je rappelle que cette semaine nous avons
consacré un dossier sur les mers des
yvelines il est à retrouver sur tv
soixante dix huit points comme dans
l'actualité également l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines a lancé fin
septembre une vaste opération digitale
de recrutement pour les jeunes nommé i
job dating est prévue du 13 au 15
octobre
l'opération doit encourager et soutenir
l'insertion des jeunes dans le milieu
professionnel
si cela vous intéresse vous pouvez
directement vous inscrire sur le site
internet de saint quentin en yvelines
revenons maintenant sur ce qui a fait
l'actualité cette semaine
[Musique]
depuis 15 jours les salariés de
l'entreprise du secteur aéronautique
permaswage sont en grève
le directeur général a annoncé un plan
social l'entreprise pourrait être
délocalisée avec une suppression de 73
postes d'ici le printemps les précisions
de justin brasier et grégory canal et
l'entreprise permaswage a souffert de la
crise sanitaire
la baisse de son activité a été
conséquente près de 40%
si les salariés s'attendaient à un plan
social avec une suppression de 60 postes
au départ aujourd'hui le projet est tout
autre il y a un plan social qui était
prévu avec des plans de départs
volontaires pour une quantité de 73
personnes et ensuite bassila
délocalisations ce fait il y en a un
deuxième plan avec le reste tout le
reste du personnel qui ne veut pas aller
dans la drôme donc si on fait un bilan
ça nous fera à peu près 150 personnes
dans la compréhension face à la
délocalisation la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois a rencontré les
syndicats et le directeur général de la
société je lui ai fait part de mon
accrue moment d'incompréhension des
difficultés qu'il serait amené à
rencontrer s'ils poursuivaient dans
cette délocalisation
néanmoins toute cette décision finale
lui appartient je peux comprendre une
réduction de charges donc une réduction
des effectifs
par contre absolument pas une
délocalisation totale en grève depuis
quinze jours les salariés sont debout
pour montrer leur désaccord face au
projet il espère encore pouvoir stopper
la délocalisation dans la drôme il est
conscient qu'il ya une situation
économique qui fait qu' il faut des
licenciements ou faut une partie qui va
s'en aller avec des départs volontaires
etc
mais quelle complètement déplacé le site
on nous tous on croit que c'est faisable
pour que ça change c'est eux qui
s'endorment
il faut qu'on reste dehors qu'on
persiste et tant que la part va pas
lâcher on va lui dire nous on est là on
restera là
la direction n'a pas souhaité répondre à
nos questions et s'est exprimé via un
communiqué elle justifié le plan social
à part une baisse de commandes clients
mais explique avoir initié des
discussions avec les représentants
syndicaux
d'ici le printemps 2000 21 73 postes
pourraient être supprimés et
l'entreprise est délocalisée dans la
drôme la question est sur toutes les
lèvres des restaurateurs allons nous
devoir bientôt fermer l'inquiétude monte
dans les yvelines entre perte de
clientèle perte d'exploitation et moral
au plus bas
la crise sanitaire et prouve la
profession depuis les annonces on arrive
une semaine qui quand même bien plus
légère en termes de réserves ils sont
inquiets pendu aux lèvres du
gouvernement sur de possibles nouvelles
mesures liées à la crise sanitaire les
restaurateurs des yvelines ne savent pas
vraiment à quoi s'attendre
un tant soit peu rassurés du maintien de
l'ouverture de leurs voisins de paris et
de la petite couronne la grande couronne
n'en reste pas moins aux aguets c'est le
cas à voisins le bretonneux
le nouveau protocole ne nous concerne
pas pour l'instant directement
il ya des risques qu'un jour ça
descendre jusqu'à nous donc l'attrait un
petit peu plus compliqué il a un petit
peu plus contraignant
ce qui m'inquiète le plus entre nous
c'est que on a un métier normalement de
convialité d'accueil de chaleur et que
aujourd'hui on met beaucoup de distance
et ça c'est un petit peu un crève coeur
pour nous restaurateurs car c'est un
lieu de rassemblement des changes
normalement à jussiê dans le nord des
yvelines en plus de la crainte de la
fermeture
c'est aussi la perte de clientèle qui
préoccupent les professionnels de la
restauration on leur impose déjà pas mal
de protocoles et si en plus il ya encore
et encore et encore d'autres protocoles
à mettre en place
je pense que les gens finiront par plus
sortir du tout quoi à l'heure actuelle
le couple ne veut pas perdre espoir et
continue d'assurer le service
c'est de garder le contact avec les
clients qui nous restent et qui sont
courageux l'a toujours sortir à devoir
nous soutenir parce que la plupart qui
viennent ils sont quand même dit dans
une démarche de soutien
un soutien que le couple de
restaurateurs de jausiers aimerait aussi
obtenir de la part de leur assureur ils
ont rejoint le collectif resto ensemble
pour demander un dédommagement pour la
perte d'exploitation durant le
confinement
environ 90 milles euros encore un autre
sujet d'inquiétude
octobre rose la campagne de
communication destinée à sensibiliser
lisez au cancer du sein est lancé et ce
jusqu'au 31 octobre
depuis une dizaine d'années le centre
régional de coordination des dépistages
des cancers accompagne les femmes dans
les yvelines
reportage d'astrid bergère et de michael
et me d'euros depuis 2004 le dépistage
organisé du cancer du sein a été
généralisé dans les yvelines quarante
mille dépistages ont lieu tous les ans
grâce à cette antenne du centre régional
de coordination des dépistages des
cancers
un service public qui accompagne les
femmes dès l'âge de 50 ans donc on
reçoit notre les femmes reçoivent notre
invitation
elles prennent rendez-vous dans un
centre de radiologie donc nous on
adresse avec l'invitation une liste de
radiologue agréé au dépistage organisé
et les femmes vont passer donc tous les
deux ans si tout se passe bien
une mammographie de dépistage organisé
jusqu'à l'âge de 74 ans les centres de
coordination des dépistages des cancers
est aussi là pour contrôler une deuxième
fois les résultats des mammographies on
reçoit les mammographies après que les
femmes aient répondu à nos invitations
de dépistage organisé et est passé dans
un premier temps leur mammographie dans
un centre de radiologie du département
où d'ailleurs partir du moment où elles
ont été considérées normal par le
premier lecteur dans le centre
d'imagerie elles viennent à la structure
de gestion pour être lue par un second
radiologue avant d'être retournés aux
femmes avec la conclusion finale
la dizaine de personnes qui travaillent
dans cette structure accompagne donc les
femmes pendant tout le processus de la
sensibilisation de l'importance du
dépistage jusqu'au résultat
au total 250 femmes sont dépistées
positives au cancer du sein chaque année
dans les yvelines
grâce au dépistage généralisé rénové et
coloré le gymnase de coignières s'est
refait une beauté
depuis lundi 5 octobre le gymnase a pu
rouvrir ses portes aux associations
sportives et culturelles
s'il ya 200 go s'est rendu sur place
après neuf mois de rénovation le gymnase
de coignières a rouvert depuis lundi
seulement le rez-de-chaussée l'ouverture
de la mezzanine est prévue pour le 14
octobre après le passage de la
commission de sécurité
on avait besoin en effet de la
rénovation de cet équipement aujourd'hui
les premières associations qui
visiter les lieux sont ravis pour dire
on le serait à moins c'est vraiment une
très très belle rénovation la quinzaine
d'enfants de l'association l'école des
sports a pu fouler en premier le seul
refait à neuf très heureux depuis le
temps qu'on l'attend effectivement il
était très attendue par les utilisateurs
et on est très contentes de pouvoir
ouvrir et les enfants en priorité on est
là qui s'amusent bien déjà sur le
nouveau terrain qui est coloré très
pratique
en plus des associations sportives les
écoles et les collèges pourront
également utiliser cet équipement
au total le montant des rénovations
atteint 2 millions 56 mille euros un
budget qui a servi à installer un mur
d'escaladé avec plusieurs niveaux de
difficulté une salle de fitness et un
ascenseur pour l'accessibilité des
personnes à mobilité réduite
on a refait intégralement les vestiaires
et les douches parce que ça ça
nécessitait on a refait le chauffage
intégralement
on a refait tout l'éclairage aujourd'hui
grâce à ces travaux qu'on a fait en
termes d'économie d'énergie
on va économiser peu près 20% d'énergie
par rapport au gymnase précédent donc
c'est quand même là un gain substantiel
les parents venus chercher leurs enfants
ce jour là ont pu constater les travaux
finis ils bien équiper toutes les
installations d'un de super gymnase on
peut faire du handball du futsal
vraiment bien bien profité
l'inauguration officielle du gymnase est
prévue autour du 12 décembre et les
cogner rien sont invités à visiter
l'équipement pour la première fois le
lycée hôtelier de saint quentin en
yvelines organisée la sélection
régionale du concours du meilleur
croissant au beurre d'isigny objectif
pour les huit jeunes apprentis se
qualifier pour la finale nationale les
heures
[Musique]
huit candidates ou sans formation en
boulangerie pâtisserie et âgés de 16 à
18 ans s'affrontaient ce jeudi au lycée
hôtelier de saint quentin en yvelines
il participait à la sélection régionale
ile de france du concours du meilleur
croissant au beurre d'isigny et chacun
avait sa petite raison pour moi bah déjà
pas d'avoir un aperçu d'un premier
concours parce que c'est le premier que
je fais et puis pour voir mes capacités
un peu aussi vont je me situe dans la
profession se mettre face à ses acquis
et s'améliorer c'est juste pour avoir de
l'expérience prendre du plaisir aussi
tester des concours ça fait toujours une
petite sensation et c'est ça qu'on
recherche en fait de l'entraînement pour
plus premier set c'est d'améliorer ma
technique est d'apprendre plus pour
espérer gagner en expérimentation
créé par l'association des professeurs
de boulangerie et la crème les désigne
cette 15e édition du concours demandé
aux candidats de réaliser 24 croissant
il doit être régulier donc ça c'est un
des principaux critères la régularité du
croissant les qualités gustatives
donc on doit avoir un bon goût de
viennoiseries au beurre ils doivent
également être courbé donc
ça veut dire qu'on repli les extrémités
des viennoiseries
l'objectif pour eux il est de valoriser
leur travail leur savoir faire
puisque c'est vraiment voilà on est dans
un métier artisanal et les deux
apprentis qui ont le mieux valoriser
leur métier sont erwan du lycée hôtelier
d'etiolles et l'ivi noise salomé du
lycée de saint quentin en yvelines
ils représenteront l'île de france lors
de la finale nationale du concours les
17 et 18 novembre prochains en normandie
le festival bd de buc revient pour une
27e édition ce week-end cette année les
événements en lien avec le festival ont
été réalisés en amont c'est le cas avec
les as tu de la marsa 20 de trappes en
yvelines qui en a bénéficié
objectif toucher tous les publics avec
les ateliers bd reportage de justin
brasier un atelier bande dessinée pour
les résidents de l'esat de trappes en
yvelines un événement lien avec le
festival bd de buc objectif pour la
27ème édition rendre l'art accessible à
tous on va toucher beaucoup de public ça
peut être des scolaires ça peut être des
publics empêchés ça peut être en tout
cas réunir toutes les forces locales
autour d'un projet autour d'un outil
redoutable qui est l'outil de la bd
aller 7 de la marsa vingt cinq personnes
en situation de handicap ont participé à
la première séance jeudi dernier c'est
vraiment une vraie découverte et puis
une vraie un vrai challenge pour eux et
puis un travail de groupe
c'est à dire c'est des moments où ils se
découvrent ils découvrent d'autres
d'autres capacités
par rapport à leur handicap par rapport
au fait de pouvoir être ensemble
les ateliers sont animés par la
dessinatrice de bandes dessinées céline
olive
elle intervient dans le cadre du
festival pour accompagner les
travailleurs handicapées
c'est vraiment très très enrichissant
humainement on voit que ça leur plaît
mais comme c'est un le dessin c'est
universel en comics part ça tout le
monde comprend donc tout on peut le
faire aussi
au total l atelier bd est composé de dix
séances le but
écrire un scénario et réaliser une
planche un travail complet on leur
demandait d'écrire une histoire delà de
la ville a structuré et en a qui n'ont
jamais dessiné donc il faut ça fait
quand même beaucoup d'un coup
donc en fait on les accompagne tout au
long et en fait on pour que ce soit
cohérent enfin il ya une petite un petit
lien entre les deux on leur demande de
raconter leur leur journée de travail ou
alors ce qu'ils aient les bons moments
qu'ils ont passés dans l'établissement
les dessins seront exposés au festival
bd de but qu il se déroulera les 10 et
11 octobre prochains
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 l'hebdo
on se retrouve vendredi prochain et
d'ici là je souhaite une très bonne
soirée un très bon week end
[Musique]